[Music]
all right now let's turn our attention
to the biggest celebrity scandals of
2016 Ozzy Osbourne rocked his marriage
yet again when he got caught cheating on
Sharon Osbourne but we all watch on
national television hey Sharon took back
her dirty dog one thing that was being
reported it was that you kicked Ozzy out
of the house is he still out of the
house um no he's back and I'm out of the
house it's right for me because I
honestly at this point today have no
idea what I'm going to be doing with the
rest of my life I'm 63 years of age and
I can't keep living like this just a few
days after Sharon revealed her marriage
to Ozzy was on the rocks the couple were
together promoting his concert sources
revealed to ET that Ozzy had an affair
with hair stylist Michelle pew and when
Ozzy and Sharon reunited well it was
kind of awkward she's here tonight
supporting you she's missing my wrong
she's right on she just deserve
everything prone you right Ozzy was
saying that he couldn't do it without
you you're like his right arm he said I
mean that's got to feel good to hear
yeah it is you know it's some weight
we've been working together my lord
since 76 for we were married you know
the whole nine yards so it's been a long
time that was in may by July Sharon had
begun the heel and I just can't think of
my life without him even though he has a
job
now the biggest TV shake-up of the year
had to be Michael Strahan leaving live I
mean it was so explosive that even Kelly
rip up never saw I comment I'm gonna be
completely honest I'm fairly certain
that there are trained professional
snipers with tranquilizer darts in case
I drift too far off message that was
Kelly Ripa in April she walked out with
her exiting co-host Michael Strahan it
was her first time on the show since
learning that he was going to GMA Kelly
says she was blindsided by the news as
she had dressed her conflict with the
network head on I needed a couple of
days to gather my thoughts after 26
years with this company I earned the
right so what transpired though over the
course of a few days has been
extraordinary in the sense that it
started a much greater conversation
about communication and consideration
and most importantly respect in the
workplace Michael's last day was in May
he and Kelly co-hosted together for
nearly four years I just want to say on
behalf of myself and all of us we
couldn't be prouder of you I just want
to say um and I just wanted very
bittersweet for me and I always wanted a
thank you to everybody seven months
later still no host kelly discussed it
on watch what happens live last month
well we didn't anticipate was that we
would have such an outpouring of
interest so our list got very long very
quickly so we've been trying to keep it
as narrow as possible but then people
pop up yeah yeah
look I'd love to do it in October
Christian Slater unexpectedly through
his name into a pool of potentials along
with Jerry O'Connell and Fred Savage
ratings are down seven percent over the
last year so that does add a little bit
of urgency for the producers however at
the same time when they're looking for a
permanent co-host you don't want to rush
this process a source has told ET that
the mystique of who can get the chair is
turning out to be more appealing two
lines executive than any of the
candidates Angela from Sacramento wants
to know if you would consider a female
for the co-host oh yes yes don't be
amazing the Summer Olympics and of
course they were rocked by scandal when
gold medalist Ryan locked in a few of
his fellow swimmers got mixed up in a
great big messy lie so what's a
celebrity to do to rehab his image when
you go on dancing with the stars of
course Ryan was teamed with pro partner
Cheryl Burke and the Olympian was so
ready to put the drama over this
incident at a real gas station behind
him but Lucky's imagery have almost went
off the rails in September when two
protesters stormed the stage after his
performance excuse me excuse me
how are you feeling what were you
thinking when you saw that happen
honestly it felt like someone just
reached inside took my heart out and
just tore it to shreds take a deep
breath I was really hurt when I saw that
and I was in shock Lochte had just
finished his Foxtrot with Cheryl and
they were listening to judge Carrie Ann
Inaba as comments when two men disrupted
the live event they were quickly tackled
handcuffed and taken away by security
you know what I'm gonna keep moving
forward I'm gonna put this behind me and
I'm gonna better myself every day and
just you know what came here what I came
here to do and dance things started
looking up for Ryan last week Ryan
announced he's going to be a daddy he
posted this announcement kissing the
tummy of his fiancee kayla rae read
right now he has a little over six
months remaining on his suspension from
USA Swimming following the real scandal
he was booted from dancing on weekend I
think the one thing I really learned is
and I can keep fighting keep getting
back up and same positive no matter what
we were all trying to figure out what
Beyonce was talking about on her
lemonade album because she had us all
believing that JC had cheated on her the
question was and it really was the
question of the year who is Becky with
the good hair are you cheatng Jeannie
biogenic on me
you can taste the dishonesty a wheel
breath it seemed like Beyonce was
finally addressing all those jay-z
infidelity rumors these eight words
about cheating had everyone talk he
better call Becky with the good hair so
is there really a Becky with the good
here well many thought it was fashion
designer Rachel Roy ex-wife of Jays
former business partner Damon Dash and
whether all this was part of art or real
life Rachel posted this Instagram good
hair don't care would later denied the
becky rumor and then there was jay-z's
former Protege Rita Ora she was also
taunting to hide and the rumors that
she's the real Becky she stepped out
wearing the exact same Gucci dress
Beyonce wore in her formation video
Reena ultimately denied the Becky rumors
on social media and also said quote I
have nothing but the utmost respect for
Beyonce let's continue enjoying lemonade
the real Becky speculation wasn't also
serious Laurie Lachlan Becky from full
house posted this and joke wasn't me and
it's safe to say it also wasn't James
Corden who won everything with this
spoof that make you laugh like Jimmy
with the good hair wait what was I
talking about oh yeah that's right a
recipe for lemonade I will say this
putting all of her supposed dirty
laundry on Front Street was good
business for Beyonce we don't really
know what happened but we all know that
the lemonade albums board nine Grammy
nomination
[Music]
you